Коли вона ворушиться, я розмовляю з нею.
Ввечері, коли я приділяю увагу своїм дітям, читаю їм казки,
то, буває, звертаюсь і до неї - не тільки до своїх.
Кінець лютого 2019-го року. Наталія - на дев’ятому місяці вагітності.
Але дівчинка, яку вона незабаром народить - не її донька.
Адже Наталія - сурогатна мати.
Вона лише виношує дитину для генетичних батьків - подружжя з Німеччини.
Авжеж, я радітиму за них. Це ж така втіха -
вперше взяти свою дитину на руки.
Рідні донька і син Наталії сьогодні приїхали до неї в гості.
Адже на останніх місяцях вагітності сурогатні мами
з інших міст переїжджають до Харкова - поближче до клініки.
Власна домівка Наталії, де вона живе з цивільним чоловіком і дітьми
- у невеликому містечку за п’ятдесят кілометрів звідси.
Наталія робить все це, щоб заробити гроші.
Адже в її рідному місті роботи майже немає,
а чоловік отримує лише близько 6 тисяч гривень на місяць.
Саме безгрошів’я стало поштовхом до рішення
виносити дитину для чужих людей.
Скільки складатиме її винагорода за вагітність, Наталія нам не каже.
Але це будуть декілька річних бюджетів родини.
Звичайно, наша мрія - поставити на ноги наших власних дітей.
Адже у нас в країні з роботою зараз туго, дітей виховувати важко.
Ми пішли на це, щоб у майбутньому їм жилося краще, ніж нам.
Оплатити дітям навчання і заснувати власний бізнес - про це мріє Наталія.
У своєму рідному місті вона не перша сурогатна мама.
Про можливість за гроші допомогти чужим людям
здійснити бажання мати дітей Наталія дізналася від знайомої.
У неї досі залишається чимало питань:
як практичних, так і радше філософських.
Мені от цікаво - зараз вона чує російську,
але ж народиться німкенею.
Настає час прощатися.
Бабусі Любі привіт!
У цю клініку на околиці Харкова приїздять пари
з усього світу, щоб здійснити мрію про дітей.
Серед них і батьки з Німеччини, чию доньку
зараз виношує сурогатна мама Наталія.
Спілкуватися з нами на камеру вони відмовилися -
не хочуть, щоб їх упізнали вдома.
Натомість розповісти свою історію погодилася ця німкеня.
Ми називатимемо її Анною - своє справжнє ім'я
вона попросила не розголошувати.
Анні трохи за 40. Вона шість разів намагалася завагітніти
за допомогою штучного запліднення - марно.
Усиновлювати чужу дитину вони з чоловіком не захотіли.
Отже, єдиним виходом для них стало сурогатне
материнство з донорською яйцеклітиною.
Проте у Німеччині це заборонено.
Лицемірство - вважає жінка.
У Німеччині сурогатне материнство заборонене.
Хоча дуже багато знаменитостей і просто людей
з грошима, які можуть собі це дозволити,
користуються такими послугами.
Проте у службі у справах дітей на тебе дивляться,
як на справжнього злочинця.
Для цієї харківської клініки подібні випадки - вигідний бізнес.
Ціни на сурогатне материнство з донорською яйцеклітиною
тут починаються від приблизно 30 тисяч євро,
каже нам лікар, відповідальний за такі програми.
Деякі батьки сплачують і вдвічі більше -
все залежить від індивідуальних побажань.
В Україні кількість сурогатних вагітностей сягає вже сотень на рік.
Причому попит зростає - особливо тепер,
коли Індія і Таїланд заборонили сурогатне материнство для іноземців.
Клієнти приїздять навіть з Латинської Америки та Австралії.
Сьогодні Україна є Меккою сурогатного материнства.
Причини прості: гарантовані програми коштують
стільки ж, скільки в Америці лише одна спроба.
По-друге, у свідоцтві про народження генетичні батьки записані як мати і батько.
По-третє, це лояльність українського законодавства.
Кінець березня. Від нашої останньої з Наталією зустрічі минуло близько місяця.
Вона вже повернулася до своєї родини.
А дівчинка, яку вона виношувала протягом 9 місяців -
вже зі своїми німецькими батьками.
Вони забрали її відразу після народження.
Після пологів, коли я її побачила, це було дивне відчуття.
Ти ніби і розумієш, що вона чужа, але все-таки цікаво
подивитись, яка вона - ти ж її виношувала 9 місяців.
І просто цікаво подивитись, як вона виглядає.
А щодо власне материнських почуттів,
то я вам скажу, що я не відчувала, що це моє.